Hello everybody!
We are Pongfinity
Welcome to a new episode of Challenge Pongfinity
This is the series where you challenge us
with crazy table tennis ideas.
Where is my racket?
Here I am!
There you are!
84 % of you watching have not subscribed our channel yet
So remember to hit that button!
This is easy!
Smash!
Next we will change sides.
At least 5 times around the world!
How many has it been?
I think we have done 7 now.
Yeah, it's really difficult!
Table tennis with a golf club.
That was a pretty good shot!
Here comes my golf serve!
Take cover!
This is jackpot material!
Good swing!
Thanks for watching guys!
Remember to subscribe to our channel here!
And watch our previous episodes there!
Until next time!